c'est toujours leur de barbarie ça avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli ajouté gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être rick bien vu l'émission
par exemple quand tu sais moi comme ça
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh ben il va animer vanille mais il m'a
dit vas-y bas animalité joliette alors
et vous l'aurez excusez nous on est en
direct excuses et enora malagré qui est
partie d'elle-même
allez-y juste utiliser un oui je vais
lui prêter mon oreillette mais gestion
pouvant avoir une haute après parce que
les maladies ça va jouer des achats
travaux
merci à résister ici bas à les y animer
cette émission alesi bon et n'aura elle
est où la seule personne qui était pas
là qu'elle a appris dans cette émission
j'ai appris que quand on avait une
morphologie en valais et au niveau du
temps se faire un bon temps pour de bon
fond de stocks et quand on a les cheveux
cramer comme toi tu les as par exemple
là bas tu te fais un truc avec dans une
dérive
je me suis trompé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]